Dans les services juridiques,
elle parcourt les preuves légales
mieux qu'un homme de loi.
On l'utilise pour conduire l'avion qui vous a transporté ici.
Les humains n'ont piloté que sept ou huit minutes,
le reste du temps, c'était l'IA.
Et bien sûr, Netflix et Amazon,
qui font leurs recommandations en tâche de fond.
C'est notre réalité.
Et un exemple plus visible, bien sûr,
est la victoire d'AlphaGo, qui a battu le champion du monde de Go.
Mais c'est plus que ça.
Si vous jouez à un jeu vidéo, vous jouez contre une IA.
Pourtant récemment, Google a enseigné à son IA
à apprendre comment jouer aux jeux vidéo.
Même si enseigner les jeux vidéos avait déjà été fait,
apprendre à jouer à un jeu vidéo est un pas supplémentaire.
C'est de la subtilité artificielle.
Ce que nous faisons est de prendre cette subtilité artificielle
et nous la rendons de plus en plus subtile.
Il y a trois aspects de cette tendance générale
qui, je pense, sont sous-estimés ;
je pense que nous comprendrions bien mieux l'IA
si nous comprenons ces trois choses.
Je pense que ces choses vont nous aider à adopter l'IA,
car c'est seulement en l'adoptant que nous pourrons l'orienter.
Nous pouvons diriger le spécifique en adoptant la tendance.
Je vais donc vous parler de ces trois aspects.
Le premier : c'est que notre propre intelligence ne comprend pas bien
ce qu'est l'intelligence.
Nous pensons souvent l'intelligence comme n'ayant qu'une dimension,
comme un son qui devient de plus en plus fort.
Ça commence avec la mesure du QI.
Il y en a d'abord peut-être un niveau bas chez un rat ou une souris,
il y en a peut-être un peu plus chez un chimpanzé
et encore un peu plus chez une personne idiote,
puis vient la personne moyenne, comme moi,
puis arrive le génie.
Et cette intelligence de QI devient de plus en plus grande.
C'est totalement faux.
Ce n'est pas ça l'intelligence, ce n'est pas l'intelligence humaine.
C'est plus comme une symphonie de différents sons
et chaque note est jouée sur un instrument de la cognition.
Nous avons plusieurs types d'intelligences :
le raisonnement déductif,
l'intelligence émotionnelle,
l'intelligence spatiale,
il y en a peut-être 100 types différents, qui sont tous regroupés
et dont la force varie selon les individus.
Et bien sûr, concernant les animaux, ils en ont tout un autre panel,
une autre symphonie d'intelligences différentes,
et quelquefois ils ont les mêmes instruments que les nôtres.
Ils peuvent penser de la même façon, mais s'organiser différemment
et sont parfois plus performants que les humains,
comme la mémoire à long terme de l'écureuil est phénoménale,
car il peut se rappeler où il a enterré ses noix.
Et dans d'autres cas, ils le sont moins.
Lorsqu'on veut faire des machines,
on va les concevoir de la même manière,
avec une intelligence plus développée que la nôtre
et même très éloignée de la nôtre,
car on n'en a pas besoin.
Nous allons donc prendre ces choses,
ces amas artificiels,
et on ajoutera plus de types de cognition artificielle à nos IA.
On va les faire très, très spécifiques.
Ainsi votre calculatrice est déjà plus performante que vous en calcul ;
votre GPS en navigation spatiale,
Google, Bing en mémoire à long terme.
Et on va prendre, à nouveau, ces sortes de pensées différentes
et les mettre dans, disons, une voiture.
La raison pour laquelle on veut les mettre dans une voiture,
c'est qu'elle ne conduit pas comme nous
et ne pense pas comme nous.
C'est son point fort.
Elle n'est jamais distraite,
ne s'inquiète pas de savoir si le four est resté allumé
ou si elle aurait dû être diplômée en finance.
Elle conduit seulement.
(Rires)
Elle ne fait que conduire.
On pourrait même faire la publicité
de « l'absence de conscience ».
Elle n'a pas de conscience ;
elle n'est pas gênée par d'autres choses ;
elle n'est pas distraite.
Ainsi en général, ce que nous essayons de faire
est de diversifier les types de pensées autant que possible.
On va meubler l'espace
avec tous les différents types ou espèces de pensées.
Et il y aura même quelques défis
très difficiles dans le domaine des affaires, des sciences
que notre propre type de pensée humaine ne pourra pas résoudre seule.
On aurait besoin d'un plan en deux phases,
qui est d'inventer de nouvelles façons de penser
avec lesquelles on pourra travailler afin de résoudre ces très gros défis,
comme l'énergie noire ou la gravité quantique.
Nous créons de l'intelligence étrangère.
Vous pouvez imaginer ceci comme des sortes d'extra-terrestres artificiels,
en quelque sorte.
Ils vont nous aider à penser différemment,
car penser différemment est le moteur de la création
de la fortune, de la nouvelle économie.
Le second aspect est que l'on va utiliser l'IA
pour faire une véritable seconde Révolution industrielle.
La première Révolution industrielle était basée
sur l'invention de ce que j'appelle la puissance artificielle.
Avant elle,
pendant la Révolution agricole,
tout ce qui était fabriqué, l'était par la force musculaire humaine
ou animale.
C'était la seule façon de faire les choses.
La grande innovation pendant la Révolution industrielle a été
de dompter la vapeur et les énergies fossiles,
pour produire cette puissance artificielle que nous pouvons utiliser
pour faire tout ce que l'on veut.
Ainsi lorsque vous roulez sur l'autoroute,
vous commandez 250 chevaux, du bout des doigts,
la puissance de 250 chevaux,
que nous utilisons pour bâtir des gratte-ciel, des villes, des routes,
pour faire des usines qui vont produire à la chaîne des chaises et des frigos,
au-delà de notre propre puissance.
Et cette puissance artificielle peut aussi être distribuée dans un réseau filaire
vers toutes les maisons, usines, fermes.
Tout le monde peut acheter cette puissance artificielle,
juste en branchant un truc.
Ça a aussi été une source d'innovation
car un fermier a pu prendre une pompe manuelle,
y ajouter cette puissance artificielle, l'électricité,
et avoir une pompe électrique.
Et si vous multipliez ça par mille ou par dizaines de milliers,
ce processus nous a apporté la Révolution industrielle.
Tout ce que nous voyons, tout le progrès dont nous bénéficions,
vient du fait que nous l'avons fait.
Et nous allons faire de même maintenant avec l'IA.
Nous allons la distribuer sur les réseaux
et vous allez prendre cette pompe électrique,
lui ajouter une intelligence artificielle,
et voilà la pompe intelligente.
Et ceci, multiplié des millions de fois,
sera la seconde Révolution industrielle.
Maintenant la voiture conduit sur l'autoroute
ses propres 250 chevaux, avec en plus 250 cerveaux.
C'est la voiture autonome,
comme un nouveau produit,
avec de nouveaux services.
L'IA va déferler sur le réseau, le cloud,
à l'instar de l'électricité.
Donc tout ce que nous avons électrifié,
va maintenant être cognifié.
Et, je le dois à Jeff,
la recette pour les 10 000 prochaines start-ups
est très, très simple :
prenez une chose X et ajoutez de l'IA.
C'est la recette de ce que nous allons faire.
C'est la façon dont nous allons créer
cette seconde Révolution industrielle.
Et au fait, en ce moment même,
on peut aller sur Google
et acheter de l'IA pour 6 centimes, 100 résultats.
C'est disponible immédiatement.
Ainsi le troisième aspect
est que lorsque l'on donne un corps à cette IA,
on obtient un robot.
Ces robots vont devenir des « bots ».
Ils vont faire beaucoup de tâches que nous avons déjà faites.
Un métier est un groupe de tâches,
ils vont donc redéfinir nos métiers
car ils vont faire certaines de ces tâches.
Mais ils vont aussi impliquer de nouvelles catégories,
une nouvelle flopée de tâches
qu'on ne savait même pas vouloir faire auparavant.
Ils vont vraiment engendrer de nouveaux types de métiers,
de nouvelles sortes de tâches à faire faire,
tout comme l'automatisation a apporté un ensemble de nouvelles choses
dont nous n'avions pas besoin avant
et dont on ne peut plus se passer.
Donc ils vont produire encore plus de métiers qu'ils vont en détruire,
mais il importe que de nombreuses tâches à leur faire faire soient celles
qui peuvent être définies en termes d'efficacité ou de productivité.
Si vous pouvez décrire une tâche,
qu'elle soit manuelle ou conceptuelle,
pouvant être conçue en termes d'efficacité ou de productivité,
elle sera pour les robots.
La productivité est pour les robots.
Car là où nous sommes vraiment bons, c'est dans la perte de temps.
(Rires)
On est très doués à faire des trucs inefficaces.
La science est intrinsèquement inefficace.
Elle se développe sur des successions d'échecs,
sur le fait qu'on fait des tests et des expériences qui ne marchent pas,
sinon on n'apprend pas.
Elle se développe car il n'y a pas beaucoup d’efficacité en elle.
L'innovation est inefficace par définition.
car on fait des prototypes
et on essaye des trucs qui échouent, qui ne vont pas.
L'exploration est intrinsèquement inefficace.
L'art n'est pas efficace.
Les relations humaines ne le sont pas.
Voilà les types de choses vers lesquelles nous allons,
car elles sont inefficaces.
L'efficacité est pour les robots.
Nous allons aussi devoir apprendre à travailler avec ces IA,
car elles pensent différemment de nous.
Quand Deep Blue a battu le champion du monde d'échecs,
on a pensé que c'était la fin des échecs.
Mais en fait, il s'avère que le champion du monde d'échec aujourd'hui
n'est pas une IA.
Et n'est pas un humain.
C'est l'équipe formée par un humain et une IA.
Le meilleur diagnosticien n'est ni un médecin, ni une IA,
c'est leur équipe.
Nous allons travailler avec ces IA.
Je pense que l'on sera payé dans le futur
selon notre capacité à travailler avec ces robots.
La troisième chose est donc qu'ils sont différents,
qu'on va les utiliser
et qu'on va travailler avec plutôt que lutter contre eux.
Nous travaillerons avec plutôt que contre.
Donc, le futur :
où cela nous mène-t-il ?
Je pense que d'ici 25 ans, on regardera en arrière
à notre compréhension de l'IA et on dira :
« Vous n'aviez pas d'IA. En fait, vous n'aviez pas encore d'Internet,
comparé à celui que nous aurons dans 25 ans. »
Actuellement, il n'y a pas d'experts en IA.
Beaucoup d'argent va arriver,
des milliards de dollars seront dépensés,
c'est un secteur économique énorme,
mais il n'y a pas d'experts, comparé à ce que nous aurons dans 20 ans.
Nous en sommes au début du début,
à la première heure de tout cela.
Nous sommes à la 1ère heure d'Internet,
à la 1ère heure de tout ce qui vient.
Le produit intelligent le plus populaire dans 20 ans,
que tout le monde utilisera,
n'a pas encore été inventé.
Ça signifie que vous n'êtes pas encore dépassé.
Merci.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)